c'est gilles verdez l'homme de tous les
excès il devrait apprendre à fermer sa
gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on aura également jeté au fond d'la qui
viendra le voir devant l'instance chaque
chroniqueur va rentrer en christophe
hondelatte et aura une révélation ou un
reproche à faire sur l'accusé de son
choix lui c'est maxime gagné il serait
il ne serait pas l'auteur de tous ses
scoops
maxime koenig je vous le demande est-il
un usurpateur
excusez moi c'est ça le là c'est
benjamin castaldi
l'escroc de ses huit alias l'animateur
discount tout ce qu'il touche
ça ne marche pas à challandes les
présentations ne touche pas à mon poste
big le quiz alors jusqu'à quand larnack
va-t-elle durer
lui c'est jean michel maire la dernière
fois qu'il a bossé 189 depuis pas une
émission de télé il a vu pas un film il
a vu pas une info ou des données là moi
j'ai fait ça vous et comment un emploi
fictif c'est gilles verdez
l'homme de tous les excès colérique
folle et décapante
il devrait apprendre à fermer sa gueule
lui c'est cyril hanouna le dark vador du
post
il était obsédé par le rire par les fous
rires
mais cette agitation intempestives ne
traduit-elle pas une angoisse absolue la
peur de disparaître
voire de mourir ah ouais quand même
elle c'est mamie zinzin aussi appelé la
vioque au piment rouge
voilà pourquoi en interrogeant pendant
plusieurs heures une centaine de voisins
les gendarmes d'apprendre que quatre
choses elle a travaillé dans un zoo elle
a fait pékin express est là étaient
comestibles
elle fait l'amour
panacotta chaque week-end avec un
certain alain à certains là qui va mener
les gendarmes
un nouveau rebondissement car la vioque
a plus d'un tour dans son sac
maxime guény je t'accuse aujourd'hui tu
te fais passer pour le tombeur de ces
dames
alors qu'au final j'ai appris que tu
étais un enquêteur un vrai enquêteurs tu
te renseignes auprès de mes amis pour
savoir avec qui je sors
j'aimerais te dire juste une chose pose
moi les questions à moi
[Musique]
merci le shérif vers sic et libertés on
a pris des gosses
[Musique]